let's begin with what was i think the
game of the day exciting game maybe a
super bowl preview who the hell knows
rams at bills
and chris look
every week when we decide
to start football night in america best
thing you saw right out of the gates
it's always josh allen for you but josh
allen really was the best thing that you
saw on sunday after watching the game
again do you still feel as strongly
about josh allen being the best thing
you saw on sunday i i definitely do yeah
i do i mean you know again and like
obviously i like josh allen i'm a fan of
his i became more of a fan of his
because you know this certain group that
wouldn't give him any respect either
when he got in the nfl or we left with
college it was always just trying to put
them down put them down put them down
and usually when you do to the guys like
that that are talent that i want to
latch on and go let's go put them up put
them up put them up here we go and
the last three weeks i i realistically
think he's been the best thing i've seen
on sunday i mean when it comes time to
do
talk and yeah you know we don't know the
end of the four o'clock games maybe i
would have picked russell wilson if i
saw that game in totality last week
certainly but josh it's the josh allen
show in buffalo everything they're doing
is predicated because josh allen has a
skill set that is scary scary good it is
up there i'm not going to say with my
homes but it's the next level guy down
right now it really is i mean all the
things they do with him i mean you talk
about throwing the ball down the play
okay throwing the ball down the field
aggressive that way he extends plays
they're running quarterback option
wishbone stuff to the left quarterback
drop
quarterback draws option to the right
for touchdowns and they do some of them
a home stuff too where they just tell
him hey drop back really deep and we're
going to send people deep really far
down the field and he either makes a
great throw or he's created space like
mahomes to where then he avoids the pass
rush and makes other great plays off
schedule so he is absolutely a baller in
the nfl right now and we know mahomes is
the best quarterback in the game and
russell wilson's probably played the
best through three weeks of football
there's no doubt about that but josh
allen is nipping at the heels of both of
those guys to be like hey hey i'm pretty
awesome too and there's no doubt it is
the josh allen show and what they're
doing right now is because of him and
his skill and they built something
around him
i agree with you and he is definitely on
the right side of that line that we've
kind of identified where the
quarterbacks who can run the play that's
called as long as everything goes as
it's supposed to it'll be fine and the
quarterbacks who can find a way to
extend a play that falls apart make
things happen with their feet by time
and throw the ball down the field while
on the run or just take off and run and
get the first down or the touchdown that
way josh allen clearly is in that that
handful of quarterbacks who can do it at
a high level right the difference i see
when you watch it play after play after
play and that's one of the great things
about the game pass feature i don't know
why i'm going so all in on this but i
hey hey i recognize when there's a great
product
the condensed version of the game which
gives you one play after another after
another where you can watch it in 45
minutes but you get into that rhythm and
you see and it's there's a there's a
vibe that comes through when you watch
it one after another after another
for him
there's an element chris
where
he's right on the edge of being out of
control right right where patrick
mahomes is running around hair on fire
but you know at the end of the day he's
going to jump out the window and he's
going to be fine right with josh allen
you'd never quite know what the hell is
going to happen yeah and sometimes
something happens other than what
patrick mahomes would do in that moment
and he makes one of those what in the
hell was that type decisions
and and that that's part of what you
have to accept you're going to have
uh you know with patrick homes you're on
the edge of your seat but you're like
this is going to work out with josh
allen you're on the edge of your seat
and you're thinking what the hell is
this going to be and you really don't
know until it happened no you're you're
right there's still a little bit of like
you know playing with his hair on fire
moments there's no doubt
but
don't all i would say is don't let old
narratives continue to beat you down
when the guy's thrown for over a
thousand yards and ten touchdowns and
one interception
and but the old narrative was he's not
an accurate passer well yeah i know i
know the old narrative is incorrect when
you play up in blizzards and like up in
montana and the receivers and the
receivers suck and the whole team sucks
and it was the worst offensive line
i mean really that i don't that's where
i that's where i started to push back
against the people were like well this
film didn't look good i want to go well
we could put my homes up there too and
it wouldn't look that good in montana
it's just the way it is and
so that bothers me but either way you're
right there's still a polish factor that
we'd like to see
but
the raw physical ability and what he did
in a rams defense that's pretty good
playing right through the first two
weeks
his ability to stay in the pocket and
avoid guys like aaron donald who made a
mess of things a number of times during
the game
you know they had a plan for him they
sled the lot slid the line his way a lot
made sure they maybe had two bodies
aware of aaron donald was but that
doesn't matter it's aaron donald he's
one of the greatest of all time he had
many times where he was still back there
but josh allen's ability to avoid him
made that you know a a mute moot point
okay i got it right i think well done
made it a point and even on the third
and 22. aaron donald buss back there
josh allen does a great job and because
the rams play a lot of zone defense
this is where josh allen's scary because
he avoids the pass rush and just like
russell or mahomes then he manipulates
the zone he looks over here he's also
running over here so the defense slides
that way and then boom he could throw it
into another hole where a receiver is
sat down he's very good that way and i
think that's one thing i took away from
the film watching it like on the coach's
film too mike is just like
the
their the rams are young and the
secondary they're a good football team
and if i was going to say something
about them and what they could do they
need to put more pressure on jalen
ramsey that would be one thing i would
look at they're playing a lot of zone
you can't pay that guy that kind of
money and not let him live on the island
a little bit and make some stops i know
there was two touchdown passes thrown on
him by stefan diggs it was phenomenal
coverage it wasn't that it was really
the only completions he let up during
the day
and he uh to me they need to ask more of
him and they'll be able to do other
creative things with their secondary
behind it once they get to that point
one last point on alan yeah you know we
we have come to accept that there are
certain quarterbacks that aren't going
to fit the mold they're not going to
have the mechanics the footwork they can
throw the ball from any arm angle
anybody position and we're not going to
be critical with allen though
it it contributes to this sense that
it's on the edge because the the posture
at times is kind of all over the place
yeah but he's still he still gets rid of
the football and it still goes to where
it's supposed to go more often than not
no you're right there's there's throws
where
you go whoa he's running around he's
moving around and his feet are all
cockeyed but yet he throws the ball you
know 20 yards this way even though his
feet were lined up to go the other way
he does have that you know there's no
doubt but you know mahomes does that too
but there's still an element of
sometimes where you go
that's just out of control like he threw
that ball too hard or it just was he
lost control of it and it flew up in the
air too high yeah i know what you're
saying there there definitely is but the
important thing is we've seen
adjustments happen about his game and i
think that's what the bills have seen
and that's why they're so confident in
them and that's why they've literally
given them the keys to the ferrari and
they're playing through him right now i
mean that's what they're doing because
the bill's defense hasn't been very
special we could talk about that too
here in a second but i think your point
you know we talked about
um you know cleaning it up a little bit
he's cleaned it up you talk about who
can he throw the ball with touch he's
making some of the greatest touch throws
every week through three weeks in the
season and i think those are all
positives to go hey the kid's obviously
coachable and aware of his issues and
he's trying to work on it and get better
and he is right in front of us
the example that just popped into my
head mahomes is like the guy who's
riding the bicycle very smoothly with
his eyes closed and josh allen is the
kid who has just finally figured out how
to keep the bite upright yeah yeah
wobbling a little bit but it's not
crashing yeah but it's constantly doing
this and you just wonder which way it's
going to go all right you mentioned the
bill's defense let's skip ahead to that
we'll come back and talk about aaron
donald okay bill's defense i i think the
rams did a great job running against the
buffalo defense not as great passing i
think they should have stuck with the
run a lot more than they did
especially on some drives in the first
half that didn't go their way
what concerns do you have about
buffalo's defense after taking a closer
look because they really struggled to
stop that running they really did the
buffalo bill front four i think has been
underwhelming through three weeks that
concerns me and i mean you're right
about the run game mike there's nothing
to say there's nothing more to say about
it other than the sean mcvay brought it
to sean mcdermott and that buffalo
defense schematically in everything they
did where this game is misleading
because it got 28 to three you think oh
buffalo must have done something right
to start the game and really shut down
the rams and no that's not the case for
anybody who wants to go back and watch
the game you'll see the rams were never
stopped throughout the day they drove
down the first drive of the game missed
a field goal they drove down the second
drive of the game and they were on field
goal range and jared goff threw a dumb
interception they drove down the third
drive of the game and got a field goal
and then they went into half and buffalo
scored the first drive of the second
half and there you go now we know that
interception call and all that changed
the game but the big thing too is
mcveigh is just a genius and if you look
at the stat sheet for the buffalo bills
the leading tacklers on their football
team were jordan poyer and tyron johnson
that's not a good thing when secondary
guys are leading your team and tackling
that tells you your front sevens not
making the tackles right and more times
than not what i found really that was
just mind-boggling to me and mcveigh is
a genius this way
he found run game design to make sure it
always went back to okay buffalo you
want to play nickel defense four
defensive lineman two linebackers well
i'm gonna find a way to that seventh guy
you're trying to cheat in the box the
nickelback that's 195 pounds we're going
to end up where the ball is going to be
running right at him and that's where
they really exposed buffalo they put
tyron johnson who's a nickel cover guy
in a spot where he was probably like
what i gotta fill the hole again and
make the tackle i gotta take on the
blocker here all of those type of things
let alone golf and everything once that
got going and really going like you're
saying then here comes the boots and
everything that goes with it and then
mcveigh and that offense just roll
you know you mentioned the bills scored
that touchdown that made it 28-3 at the
start of the second half the rams
actually had the ball before that and
they were running it effectively and
they got it to the 46 right first and
10.
a short pass gained six yards and then
second and four incomplete pass third
and four incomplete pass they went
forward on fourth and four another
incomplete pass abandoned the run in
that spot and and gave the bills a
fairly short field 52 yards they scored
the touchdown make it 28-3 but to their
credit the rams realized we just need to
run the ball and it was runs and it was
screens and it was runs and it was
screens and that's what contributed to
largely uh turning that that 25 point
deficit into a late lead yeah it did and
you know this is where buffalo's gonna
have to readjust buffalo like the rams
is a really
a zone football team you know and of
course when you're getting run on and
then it's the boots you know that zone
moves one way and all of a sudden you
know mcveigh's a master of hey we're
moving you this way but man as you're
moving this way we're gonna have
somebody coming back the other way
that's gonna stress out your zone that's
where they really got buffalo to where
that could be something they might have
to dabble with a little bit and the
other thing the buffalo bills are to get
used to is teams are going to approach
them differently you know they're
playing differently last year was about
playing through their defense managing
josh allen let's make him play let it
get you know make a play here and there
you know now def teams are playing
buffalo going
we got to push the envelope against the
bill's defense because this offense is
awesome and they're coming and they're
going to score points and make plays so
i think therefore too it's it's making
life harder on the bills because teams
are coming out you know guns ablazing
against them because they know that
their defense is going to have a hard
time stopping buffalo and that's where
it's a little different but bill's deed
definitely a little underwhelming not as
impressed with their front four this
year and kind of how they're taking over
games or not taking over games
last point fairly quickly josh allen
told me after the game that if they see
the rams again i like that attitude that
maybe they'll see them again in the
super bowl they need a better plan for
99 aaron donald
what went wrong and did anything go
right as they tried to contain and slow
down the best defensive player in the
game well you know they had moments of
where okay he didn't ruin the game and
do that but nobody stops aaron donald i
mean josh allen's ability to move and
dodge him at least you know negated some
negative
negative plays that was
a huge aspect but no he's still
everywhere causing problems everywhere
and you know the bad thing is he's so
dominant and so amazing sometimes i mean
of course the strip sack fumble that
get get set the rams up to take the lead
after all that you know he he's
unstoppable and then what's even crazy
is he's so damn good and we talked about
this last week where there's certain
plays mike
where he wins his gap so fast
and so dominant against the people that
are blocking him it truly ends up being
a bad thing for their defense like it
does because it leads a whole he flies
up there and the offensive lineman are
turned around trying to go get him but
it leaves a hole that's like 20 feet
wide sometimes and the linebacker's in
there going wait donald threw up there's
guys there now the running back has
wiggled his way back to that like lost
area and there's a huge hole and that's
i mean he's just amazing that's all i
can really say and his effects are
always there in the football game you
know the bill's just barely avoided
total disaster with him and that's the
way most teams survive against him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports